good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I'm
very proud to welcome you to this edition of
our 2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational
Health Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and Sciences
the school of data science and through a grant
from the National Institutes of General Medical
Sciences since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused on the
use of data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and statistical
modeling as they pertain to differing themes
in the biomedical and Health Sciences this
year's theme is data science and the public
health consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we will be enjoying presentations on Fridays
from leading thinkers about the issues the promise
the opportunities and the hurdles associated
with understanding the secondary health effects
of covet 19. these include delayed Health
checkups treatments mental health drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS covid-19 virus
indeed our 2022-2023 application cycle is now
open and we encourage Junior faculty members
who are working in the areas such as infectious
diseases epidemiology clinical medicine population
Health as well as data science machine learning AI
statistics and other relevant domains to consider
applying we believe that this will be an exciting
and engaging program we're characterizing the
secondary health effects of covid-19 necessitate
unique quantitative and collaborative approaches
participants selected for our biomedical data
science Innovation lab program will Leverage
The presentations such as you're going to hear
today as vital material for our culminating
in-person Grant project development Workshop
to be held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023. so today I am
delighted to welcome our speaker Dr Maria sundaram
from Marshfield Clinic Research Institute
Maria is an associate research scientist
at the Marshfield Clinic and she attended the
University of Minnesota for earning her doctoral
Philosophy degree in environmental health
Johns Hopkins University getting a Master's
in science and public health specializing
Global disease epidemiology and control and
did her Bachelor of Science work in Neuroscience
in German at the University of Wisconsin-Madison
her current research involves estimating the
burden of respiratory viruses like influenza
covid and RSV and estimating the effectiveness
of vaccines in use for them and continuing our
2022-2023 biomedical data science seminar series
theme her lecture is entitled challenges in
estimating vaccine Effectiveness using big data
in her presentation Maria is going to remind us
that estimates of covid-19 vaccine Effectiveness
rely heavily on large-scale data systems such as
national health insurance plans however there
is a temptation to believe that since these
data sets are so big and have such high penetrance
that epidemic logical bias does not play a large
role however Maria is going to Avail us of that
assumption and we'll point out that there are
several important challenges to causal inference
with big covid-19 data and she's going to walk us
through what these challenges are and discuss
possible solutions as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via YouTube
and if you are watching on YouTube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged to submit
any questions they might have via the chat feature
in their Zoom sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf during the
last 10 minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome Maria we are so excited to have
you and we're really looking forward to your
lecture thank you so much for having me um I'm
I'm really looking forward to talking about this
and all of the ways that vaccine Effectiveness
research has gotten like messed up because of
covid-19 and I hope that it'll be useful and
interesting to folks listening uh and I'm looking
forward to your questions so I just first wanted
to talk a little bit about why I care about
vaccines why why vaccines in particular for me
um there's all sorts of reasons there's probably
a lot of obvious reasons um but for me there's
a there's a couple big ones vaccines are the
only Public Health intervention to have ever
eradicated a disease this is a photo of rahima
Banu the last person to get wild uh smallpox
um it's also the only Public Health intervention
that we know of that's capable of eliminating
diseases from from uh regions in fact we can
see here um our efforts to contain polio have
been incredibly strengthened by the fact
that we have a great vaccine a great set
of vaccines and the who estimates this is actually
pre-covered um estimated that that's between 2010
2015. which is a crazy amount when you
think of the the number of possible things
um that could be happening to cause those deaths
so this is why I think vaccines are so wonderful
and important and I'm sure you don't need to hear
more from me on why vaccines are great we've all
kind of lived through an example of why vaccines
work uh over the last couple of years uh but uh
there is of course like you know a little bit of
a gap there um and so I want to tell you why not
only vaccine so there's a couple of problems
that vaccines can't solve uh for example you
know from the time that you develop this little
vaccine in a vial and you've got your syringe
to the time that it gets to the person's arm and
protects them there's a lot of intervening factors
um there can be waning immunity from the vaccine
there could be a safety signal as well for example
we saw this for covid-19 and the J J vaccine
um with immune thrombocytopenia um we could see
lags or problems in vaccine production we saw that
several times in several different ways throughout
the covid-19 pandemic and they may actually be
in environments where you maybe wouldn't expect
um for example Canada is a great example um
that at the time did not have in-country vaccine
manufacturing capability um because why would they
do that they can get it from the United States and
then during a global pandemic a respiratory virus
it actually suddenly becomes really important
that we have that capability and because Canada
didn't have that capability not only were vaccine
uh vaccines delayed for the rollout in Canada
but also they wound up taking vaccines out of
Kovacs earlier than they were supposed to and so
this kind of had Global rapper competitions just
because of the fact that they had sold their
in-country vaccine manufacturing capability
and we've seen also kind of on that same
line vaccine nationalism and how vaccines
get distributed it's not always directly related
to the amount of meat or burden that is caused
by the infectious disease that it prevents and
along those same lines vaccine Equity even more
uh in in small smaller areas in a country we can
see that vaccine Equity is really important for
a lot of different reasons as well as vaccine
hesitancy let's say we solve all those problems
that we get the person in the room and we've got
the the vaccine in the syringe and the person is
like you know what I'm just not really into it
I don't really like vaccines it's not really
my thing so that's that's also a problem we have
to get that person on board and get them excited
about getting vaccinated because it's a really
great Public Health intervention and if they're
not on board with that then all of the work
we did um doesn't doesn't really help us there
um so we have plenty of of research and work that
um kind of tries to address those particular uh
different red X's but luckily for us like once
we get the vaccine in the person we get some
nice data out and then we publish the paper and
we have done it we've like reported the the uh
how That vaccine works and it's done right
like that's the we don't need to do anymore
work okay well obviously that's not true right
so we have challenging challenges of testing
we have challenges with vaccine Equity as well
as ascertainment of whether you got vaccinated
and also whether you have covid-19 for example
um not limited to cover 19. and we also have a
lot of different violations of model assumptions
and study design requirements that are not being
followed because we really don't have control over
what's happening kind of in this like nitty-gritty
real world scenario where everything is changing
from day to day week to week and so my goal in
talking to you today is not really to solve these
problems these X's these are way above my pay
grade I just want to give you an idea of like
where there might be dragons um and the reason
I have a dragon up here is that some of you may
know this is probably like an apocryphal story but
um there is this idea that when people were
making Maps way way before now when they didn't
know what was out there um one of the practices
of map making was to draw a dragon in an area
that hadn't been explored and that was kind of
like a note to just be like well we don't know
what's out here but it could be dangerous it could
be really bad it could be a Dragon for example
um this might not actually be what that makers
really did but I like the story and I like this
illustration so my job my like goal here today
is just to tell you kind of like where are some
of the Dragons um and hopefully that will um
kind of spark some ideas about like what to do
with with the data you might already have or how
to interpret data that you're seeing reported on
so with that said vaccine effectiveness um
vaccine Effectiveness a lot of you may know
is calculated by uh taking a risk ratio or like
a relative risk of some kind uh and you know
we take it we've got like one minus that and
that's our vaccine Effectiveness estimate so
um we can evaluate this relative risk almost
any way we choose which is kind of incredible
and so this kind of starts to ask you know beg
the question vaccine Effectiveness against what
um we can look at a lot of different outcomes here
we can look at individual risk against infection
or transmission symptomatic illness severe illness
um illness progression rate how fast you get
really sick versus you know hopefully not really
thick um and we can also estimate indirect effects
of vaccine Effectiveness so VE for unvaccinated
individuals in a highly vaccinated population
um otherwise maybe referred to as heart immunity
or Community immunity or vaccine Effectiveness
or vaccinated individuals that is beyond what
the protection that they would have gotten just
from their own vaccine alone thanks to the
fact that everyone around them is vaccinated
and I just want to kind of like quote from this
paper this is the best talent paper from 1999.
she really was ahead of the curve on so many
of these things um to just you know she kind
of really makes this really great point that
in a lot of vaccine studies the distinction
between infectious infection and disease as
an outcome is not actually made and so when we
don't differentiate these protective effects it's
between infection and against disease we introduce
these non-linear causal Pathways and that could
mean that the efficacy that we're measuring
um is quite different than what we meant to
measure so I'm going to go into that a little
bit more in the next couple of slides but again
this is from this is actually from a different
that's how we're in paper in 1997. so hopefully
this is a kind of an illustration of all of the
different possible ways you could use models to
investigate vaccine Effectiveness um we have a
couple of different ways that we seem to go back
to over and over again because they seem to work
for the the different environments that we usually
see but um in a pandemic a lot of things kind of
fall apart and so we have to kind of investigate
them a little more carefully so one of the core
assumptions of observational vaccine effectiveness
of nation is that people are exchangeable people
who do get vaccinated and who don't get vaccinated
are exchangeable except for their vaccination
status so other another way to say this is they're
flip-floppable they live similar ideally identical
lives except for the fact that the theater
didn't get vaccinated but people in vaccine
Effectiveness studies can be different in really
important ways so I'm going to go now into a bunch
of stuff about covid-19 and I just want you to
try to keep in mind it's not necessarily just
restricted to covid-19 the kind of things that I'm
talking about it's just that we have the best data
and illustrations for coping 19. this is a good
example of where people who might be taking part
in a vaccine Effectiveness um data set who might
be a member of a vaccine Effectiveness data set
um are not necessarily exchangeable so this is in
New York City we can see that there is differences
um by area in the amount of tests that are
available we can also see that there's almost
like a reverse difference in the proportion
of positive tests available we can see that
that kind of maps onto socioeconomic status we
can see that it maps onto ethnicity and race
and so now we're kind of seeing like okay actually
the structure of something that we thought was
exchangeable everyone can get a test is actually
not really the case and there are some there are
some really important structural factors including
socioeconomic factors uh that are coming into play
here um and that's that's not just um we're not
just um you know talking about testing um in a
community level we're talking about testing that's
we're attempting to deliver the test directly to
people's homes uh but for tests goes a long way
uh in some homes and doesn't go a long way in some
other homes and that is also sort of differential
by these socioeconomic and racial ethnic variables
um this is a picture of uh my home state of
Wisconsin's health impact of Cova 19 by race
and ethnicity um you will not be surprised that
um although Wisconsin is a majority white State
um the number of hospitalizations per 100 000
people fell uh most heavily on black wisconsinites
unfortunately it's it's sad that this happened
it's also sad that it's not surprising
um but but it's an important component um of
our covid um a pandemic shape and then finally
I want to talk a little bit about vaccine
access so this is actually a map of Toronto
um where like the the underneath part that's
all white is um Lake Ontario so um so you can
see here that again these kind of two different
heat maps are almost flip floppable they're almost
like reverse images of each other um on the left
you see covid-19 hospitalizations on the right
you see uh the population that's vaccinated with
at least one dose and this was in April of 2021.
um and just to kind of like Hammer that point home
a little bit more um in the upper left you can
see this is a neighborhood of uh Toronto that's
uh maybe a little bit rougher around the edges
this is like the part of Toronto that Drake raps a
lot uh about um it's the intersection of Jane and
Finch and you can see here um this is a community
that could really use a lot more help and money
and structure than they currently have and you
can see in particular they don't have a lot of
pharmacies and there's also challenges in getting
people to those pharmacies and then in the bottom
right in this pink area is Mount Pleasant which is
one of the nicer neighborhoods in Toronto and I'll
I'll cop to it and tell you that I also lived in
Mount Pleasant when I was a postdoc somehow on my
postdoc salary so you can see the little blue
dot right next to this uh Pink um Square here
is pretty close to where I lived you can see uh
there's 29 pharmacies in this area as opposed to
six pharmacies that Jaden Finch and this is it's
pretty clear that like Mount Pleasant is the sort
of folks who are able to work from home who have a
lot of social capital and economic capital who are
able to access care very easily and this is maybe
not the the specific neighborhood that needs the
vaccines the most uh like you know and and the
most urgently but um because of the underlying
structures of Toronto uh that's the that's the
neighborhood that got the most vaccines up front
um and this is mirrored again uh
in Wisconsin uh vaccination rollout
um we see that there is substantial
vaccine inequity within our communities
so vaccination um not only is there kind
of this like social like underpinning of
um of vaccine inequity and testing and Equity
um there's also kind of like biological
reasons why the vaccine might do different
things for different people so vaccination
can induce heterogeneous responses and
the protection might win or be boosted
um you know based on your underlying uh
immunological condition um you might be protected
or unprotected you might have weighty immunity
over time or you might have natural immune
boosting after exposure to a wild type virus a
virus that's circulating kind of in your community
um depending on who you are you might be
susceptible to vaccine-mediated protection
um or the sorry the virus might be susceptible to
vaccine mediated protection that's why it's sad
um or depending on the virus that you get
infected with it might be a very end of
concern and it might Escape immune detection
or protection based on who you are and what
your risk factors are where work on the time
of the pandemic where you are you know needing
to be outside or interacting with people and
um there are also of course differences in
Behavior conditional on vaccination status on
the left here I have people who maybe they've
been vaccinated so now they're like they are
feeling great and they want to go out to a race
um you know on the other hand there's maybe
someone who um either is high risk and has
been vaccinated or hasn't gotten vaccinated yet
and now they're they're alone and both of these
people are in orange just to indicate that like
neither of these scenarios is great I don't want
people sitting alone by themselves on a bench so
this is this is not great so when um so I'm really
like kind of dig into some of these things and you
might be thinking well okay yeah like all of these
things are true and that's fine but this is why
we put these covariates in regression models so we
put the covaries on the regression models and then
we're done and like that solves the problem and um
I mean of course that's not entirely true but that
is why we put these things in our question models
um I want to kind of dig into where that Paradigm
falls apart a little bit so there are some times
when controlling for things in regards models
simply won't work and a great example of this
is when other things are happening at the same
time so when this happens the functional result
is we don't have anyone in our comparison groups
so in a scenario where circulation of pathogens
and the vaccination of specific risk groups are
consistent over time we can just measure vaccine
effectiveness at different times after vaccination
so we can measure it at 14 days after vaccination
or 140 days and that's that's fine but if the
circulation of the pathogen is not consistent
over time which is something that we saw for
coca-19 then different measurements of ve at
different time points could accidentally coincide
with the vaccination of a new risk group so maybe
you know we we've moved on past older adults
and Care Homes and healthcare workers now we're
starting to vaccinate middle-aged adults um so
this is like a completely new you know different
group with different underlying immunological
uh experiences repertoires and uh functions
um and that's the vaccine might work differently
for them um it could also accidentally coincide
with a sudden increased transmissibility of
a new pathogen or a subtype um the changing
of other pathogen prevention measures like for
example maybe uh throughout the course of this we
now have a directive from the local public health
department that we're supposed to cough directly
out of the eyeballs of the person sitting next
to us on the bus so anyway um you get the idea
um we as a result of these kind of structural
confounding factors ve can be biased in either
direction towards an hour away from it all
and this actually is um very very challenging
um because we don't really have a way to change
the fact that these things have already happened
policy has been enacted we can't turn back
time we can't we don't have a time machine
um but wait there's more so sometimes controlling
for these things we know our confounders uh maybe
we do have the opportunity to control for them
and uh there is no kind of structural confounding
we we feel like from a Time standpoint um things
are okay but when we put that covariate into our
regression model or when we condition on it it
makes everything worse and I'm going to try to
explain a little bit about how this works it's
called collider bias and I will say collider
bias is something that does not come intuitively
to me it probably does come intuitively to some
people but I'm not one of those people so okay
let's go through this example um oh sorry in
causal models the collider is an entity that's
caused by more than one factor in the graph I'm
about to illustrate this for you but if you are
a dag person just know that a collider is a node
that like two edges are going into so we'll go
for through this example imagine a world where
asthma has no relationship to the risk of covid-19
infections so we like underlying truth is asthma
is not related to cover 19. but we don't know
that yet and we want to investigate whether asthma
and covet are related we're interested in this
relationship we dutifully set up our causal model
here's our dag having asthma and then we have
an arrow and then identified as a covenant case
and we want to identify this Arrow
here we want to quantify that
so in order to measure this Arrow let's say
we have a pool of 100 people and 10 of whom
unbeknownst to us yet have kova 19. and of these
100 people 50 of them have asthma okay so now we
know like you know under underlying like this is
again the underlying truth we just unbeknownst
to us yet because asthma is not related to covid
although we don't know it yet asthma is randomly
distributed throughout the group and um I hope
without any further information from me you'll
be able to calculate the expected number of
covik cases in the 50 of people with asthma
I'll give you just a second to think about that
it's five so we we know that there's ten
percent of people uh in this group that
have covid and we know that asthma covet are
not related so the number of people that have
asthma covet is the same number as the number of
people without asthma who have coping it's five
so this is this is the equation here in
case you would like the equation there it is
okay so that's how it could have happened if we
did actually sample everyone we meant to and we
specified our model correctly we would get the
correct answer but that's not really how it
sometimes does happen so in reality the character
answer is a lot harder to get to because we don't
know we don't get to know about Cova cases that
aren't identified through testing so although
this wasn't explicit in our question because
of the way we're conducting our research we're
actually conditioning on getting tested for covid
and let's just say let's just make this one step
worse let's say if you can only get a test if you
have relevant symptoms like shortness of breath
um this is hopefully not too far outside
the realm of possibility from your personal
experience especially at certain points in the
pandemic where tests are not widely available or
a certain type of test is not widely available
like a PCR and so this is the real causal model
here we've conditioned on getting tested for covid
and now we've conditioned on this collider and
that introduces this relationship between asthma
and covid where there isn't one in real life
so I'll try to prove this to you now um in
our observational study structure we have
these hundred people we have 55 people who got
a Kobe test because they had coveted symptoms
we know among these 55 people whoever doesn't
have covid must have asthma this is a this is a
fake world where anyone with coveted symptoms can
only have these two causes so the risk of covid
among non-asthmatics is now one because all of
the people who had coveted asthma got tested but
the risk of covet among asthmatics is still 5 out
of 50. and because we've subset our data just to
these individuals we're able to get a covet test
we've now got a risk difference that is actually
very different than zero but this is going to
make it seem like covet is more common in people
without asthma and an alternative explanation if
you look at the data if you just look at the data
an alternative explanation is asthma protects you
against covid and I just want to underline here
this is the risk difference not the risk ratio
so we're comparing 0.9 to a null value of 0.
okay so we have the opportunity to investigate
the actual magnitude of this potential collider
bias using um individuals in Ontario Canada so I
I didn't mention this in the beginning but I did
a postdoc in Toronto um and we took while I was
living there um health information from everyone
who's enrolled in the Ontario health insurance
plan Ontario has a single-payer healthcare system
so this is 14.7 million individuals almost
every single person who lives in Ontario
and we had information about their Covenant
status we had information about a lot of
underlying health conditions like asthma COPD we
had information about their hospital visits we had
information about their age in their neighborhood
so we took a look we were like okay like what is
a determinant for getting covid-19 in Ontario
but then we started to realize we actually didn't
have an idea of like what the correct reference
group would be so I'm going to illustrate this to
you now in the First Column here we have tested
versus not tested so we're comparing people who
were tested for covid-19 versus people who are not
tested and in the second column we've got people
who tested positive versus tested negative
among all of the tested individuals and in
the last column we had testing positive versus not
testing positive so that that comparison category
now is not just testing negative it's people who
tested negatives plus people who were not tested
and as you can see here let's just go with asthma
we see that you were slightly more likely to be
tested for covid-19 if you had asthma but you were
less likely to test positive if you had asthma
and if we go down to COPD it's actually a little
bit more of a magnitude you were really like
definitely more likely to be tested for covid-19
if you had COPD less likely to test positive
but then we saw you were more likely to test
positive if the comparison group was people who
tested negative plus people who didn't get tested
okay so the 95 count of Fitness interval includes
one so maybe maybe we wouldn't like interpret
that as a big deal um but then when we look at
Hospital admissions so these are these are high
risk people people who've been admitted to the
hospital three or more times in the last three
years these are people who have some kind of like
serious underlying condition for some reason
they're definitely more likely to get tested
for cover 19. this is maybe not surprising we're
worried about them we want to make sure that they
don't have cover 19. they're less likely to test
positive if we compare them to people who test
negatives but they're more likely to test positive
if we compare them to people who test negative
plus people who are in tested because they're
tested so often and this is a statistically
significant result and not only that in in the
epidemiology world 1.38 with this like tight of
a confidence interval that's a pretty convincing
finding that's like something that you normally
wouldn't necessarily attribute to just bias
Alone um and it also kind of makes sense with our
mental model that if you are a high-risk person
you're more likely to test positive for cover 19.
and I'll kind of like again illustrate this by
age group so Inland tested versus non-cat uh not
tested category you're less likely to be tested
if you're younger in general the older you get the
more likely you are to be tested although it's
not necessarily A strictly linear relationship
and let's look at these 85 and up year olds
you are incredibly more likely to be tested
uh for kova 19 and then you're more likely to
test positive in either scenario depending on
um you know which comparison group you you
have but um the values for these differ by
an incredible amount just a huge magnitude of
difference depending on your comparison group
and so this leads to challenges interpretation
the extraordinarily challenging thing here is
that there's also biological reasons why for
example asthma might protect against covid-19
and of course conversely there's also biological
reasons why people with asthma would conceivably
have a worse time with kova 19 and I can tell
you from experience that was uh what happened
with me and so this really serves to completely
muddy the Waters of causal inference and we have
papers that are like well you know maybe it's
better if you have asthma maybe it is protective
so this is extraordinarily challenging right
because this could be due to collider bias but
it could also be a real biological finding
and Beyond the challenges of controlling
for confounders and regression models I hope this
illustrates that this there's some pitfalls in not
really knowing who's in your study population
because this is kind of what it comes back to
right like who are these people who have asthma
are they like a 36 year old who has exercise
abuse asthma because she's living a very sedentary
lifestyle after covet or is this like a 75 year
old person who's had lifelong severe asthma
there's like there's differences here right
um not knowing who is in our population can
happen really easily in scenarios when we want
an answer quickly we want the answer to be based
on a large number of people who are just living
their lives they're not in a clinical trial
it's challenging when our academic structures
don't reward community-based participatory
research or long-term engagement with the
communities that we study although that's a
whole other presentation for a different day
and it's relatively easy and fast to use
administrative data I'm not saying it's easy
and fast I'm saying it's relatively easy
and fast comparing you know compared to a
prospective cohort study or a clinical trial
we've got the data already let's just use it
so one of these pitfalls of not knowing
your population is something called the
healthy vaccinate effect so in this particular
scenario individuals who get vaccinated are more
able they're more mobile they're more likely to
access care and you can kind of think back to
the picture I showed you of the different Toronto
neighborhoods Jane and Finch versus Mount Pleasant
these people who do get access to the
vaccine may be healthier at Baseline
and they therefore might be less likely to
get the disease in question separately from
their vaccination status so being healthy
before vaccination is kind of confounding
the relationship between receiving a vaccine and
getting infected and this actually biases the
ve away from the null and it makes it look
like the vaccine works better than it does
um however in a different scenario would also
might be happening simultaneously uh we might
prioritize the vaccine first to older adults and
other individuals at high risk of the disease in
questions and in this case being unhealthy before
vaccination affects both your likelihood to
receive a vaccine and your likelihood of getting
infected so you can see how this would also bias
ve and then we have an additional sort of like
potential unhealthy vaccine effect what is the
vaccine series is more than one dose so those who
make it to two doses might actually be healthier
than those who get infected before the second
dose or unfortunately die before the second dose
um so does this mean that dose 1 presents a higher
infection risk compared to dose two pretty clearly
not but that's kind of what it looks like when you
look at the data and so both of these are going to
buy a CE towards the null make it look like the
vaccine doesn't work as well as it actually does
so it's becoming more obvious that in
addition to age high-risk health status
calendar time and sex these are kind of The
Usual Suspects confounders of respiratory virus
transmission studies we should probably also add
Healthcare seeking Behavior to the list because we
want to know like who are these high-risk people
that are always kind of coming in and needing care
and I'll also just take a moment to acknowledge
that I'm using the word Behavior but there's
all sorts of structural factors that go into
whether someone is able whether it's feasible
to seek Care at a particular time in a particular
space um so using a specific study design which
is called the test negative design we can try to
account for some of the differential Healthcare
seeking between cases and non-cases and that's
actually what this the main benefit of the test
negative design is to try to account for this
Healthcare seeking behavior I'm just going to
explain a little bit how the test negative design
Works you've got a cohort of people these people
are living in your community throughout the course
of a winter respiratory virus season or some other
kind of like you know season of and of an illness
that is preventable by a vaccine so these people
are vaccinated and some of them are not vaccinated
and a subset will come in to your clinic your
study clinic or just maybe your hospital clinic
and they'll say you know what I have a respiratory
virus I have a I have a respiratory infection uh
let's say and they'll have all of the symptoms
that um maybe make you think that they could have
the disease that you're interested in in questions
so they get pathogen tested by PCR we find out
their vaccination history through their medical
record and then we get some other demographic
information from them either from the medical
record or we we ask them directly some of
these people will turn out to be pathogen
negative and those people are test negative
people and the other group of people will
turn out to be pathogen positive um and those
are test positive people and now we have uh now
we just have to compare those people using an odds
ratio and we calculate the veas in that odds ratio
I just want to actually note here for terminology
in case anyone has heard these terms before
sometimes this is referred to as a case control
test negative design study and in fact this design
actually doesn't have much in common with the
typical case control study another way to think
about this might be a cohort study where everyone
who doesn't have the clinical case definition
gets ignored um so I'm gonna
blow my nose real quick
okay there is an important similarity however
for the test negative design to case control
studies and that's the selection in a test
negative study is based on the outcome
just like in a regular case control study this is
because only people with symptoms are seeking care
okay test negative design we use it all the
time for influenza vaccine effectiveness
um and it's kind of a logical choice for
covid-19 um vaccine Effectiveness and
I'm sure if you go on PubMed right now and
you type in sarsko V2 test negative design
you're going to find at least a thousand
papers compared to co-work studies the test
negative design is less susceptible
to misclassification of the outcome
um and it's less susceptible to confounding by
Healthcare seeking Behavior but it also carries
with a few assumptions and one of those is that
vaccinated and unvaccinated people come into
contact with infectious people at the same
rate the two distance for influenza we know
that influenza circulating of the community
it's kind of hard to tell apart from other
respiratory viruses that maybe don't cause as
much severe disease like adenovirus or rhinovirus
for covid-19 It's actually kind of a challenging
assumption to make we we do know a little bit
more uh about people's infectious status with
covid-19 than we generally do during a regular
winter flu season we assume that diagnostic
tests has high sensitivity and specificity
this is actually a pretty good assumption both
for flu and for covid-19 although the strength
of that assumption was different throughout the
course of the pandemic and it's also changing
a little bit with our you know kind of main
Reliance now on rapid tests versus PCR tests
um we also have a requirement in the test negative
design that we only include individuals who seek
care for acute respiratory illness during a
time when the pathogen of interest is actively
circulating for for covid-19 this is a pretty
decent assumption excuse me that um that it's been
circulating more or less this whole time but you
can kind of see that like we might be more likely
or less likely to find someone who's positive
based on what's happening in the community if
there's a lot of vaccine or if there's a lot of
transmission events happening in the community
versus not finally we have this core Assumption of
the test negative design that vaccination does not
affect your risk of respiratory illness caused by
a pathogen other than the one that the vaccine is
preventing so I'll kind of translate this a couple
of different ways for example flu vaccine doesn't
affect your risk of cover 19. or your risk
of respiratory synthetial virus infections so
this is a core assumption about the test negative
design because um if if it didn't affect your risk
of respiratory illness for other pathogens then
that would kind of bias our test negative group
and that's a little bit of a challenge for
food this is still it's still a pretty decent
assumption for Copa 19 it becomes a little more
challenging now because we have this group of
people let's say like a group of people who
get flu vaccine every year those people are
also the people who are going to be really
enthusiastic about getting covid-19 vaccines
so now we have like a very highly vaccinated
population against two different pathogens and
then we have like the comparison group is people
who are not vaccinated against either pathogen
and in this scenario hopefully you can kind
of see that there are some connections between
um your your covid-19 vaccination status and
then your risk of influenza or vice versa
um not intentionally and not even biologically but
just through sheer force of confounding um and I
just want to kind of add here to the test negative
design measures vaccine Effectiveness against a
medically attended acute respiratory illness so
this is functionally a component of uh infection
and severe illness right so some people will
they'll be vaccinated and they'll get some kind
of mild infection and they will never seek care
in a medical setting they won't go in to get a PCR
test they won't report this illness and we won't
know about them so your disease also does have
to be severe enough that you do seek care um in
this you know kind of particular study design okay
we haven't touched uh talked much about
this um I'm just going to talk a little
bit about it um because it's a little bit of
a bonus problem in the test negative design
um there is an entirely new layer of
complexity to these inference challenges
and we can add another season to the mix this
is relevant to influenza um we have influenza
Seasons that up until recently were pretty pretty
consistently happening over the the winter period
um but we also will very likely have this kind
of very similar almost seasonal thing happening
with covid-19 in the future maybe it won't
be exactly the same shape as influenza maybe
it won't be the same periodicity as influenza but
we can already see that there are waves happening
um and so there's going to be different times
of like Peak covid-19 transmission and infection
so you can kind of Imagine like in one season
season one on the left here we've got confounders
uh you've got a vaccination status in season one
and you've got an infection status in season two
and then like fast forward a year you have like
a you know probably like a pretty consistent set
of confounders maybe you know like your age is a
little bit different maybe your socks is the same
um you have a vaccination status in season two
and you have an infection status in season two
but you know usually kind of the way it
functionally works is that you're a person
who either does get vaccinated or doesn't get
vaccinated especially with regard to flu vaccine
people who get vaccinated
usually get vaccinated every year
um and people who don't get vaccinated don't
really care about it and don't usually get
vaccinated and so these kind of like statuses are
linked uh just by sheer force of human behavior
um and that kind of means that your vaccination
status last season could protect against your
infection status in the next season it could
protect you that long um so that's a little bit
of a challenge because now we have like this kind
of direct causal linkage between your previous
season status and your current season status
of course if you were infected last year you
might also have a reduced risk of infection this
year or maybe you're a high-risk person and you
get infected every year which really sucks but
that also um kind of like serves as this causal
linkage between your infection status and your
previous year in the current year and this kind
of serves to artificially link the confounders
in season one and the confounders in season two
and so we've looped these Seasons together to an
extent where these confounders are now related and
so if we want to assess vaccine Effectiveness
in season two we're now at the point where we
need to start going back to season one and maybe
season zero and season minus one to find out like
what were the confounders at that time because
now we've made our model sufficiently linked
together that these confounders are informative
okay so that was a lot of talking I'm just going
to recap now testing inequity coveted inequity
and vaccine inequity are not just bad for public
health they're also bad for causal immigrants so
if we really care about these as scientists we
actually really have to fight for Equity if only
for the purpose of having better data quality
knowing your population can have a really
important impact on causal inference
mechanisms by understanding the potential impact
of healthy that can be bias the potential impact
of unhealthy Saxony bias what else has happened
since you started measuring waning be for example
whether you might have collider bias and covid-19
breaks many of the rules very inconveniently with
regard to exchangeability between the tested
and untested people and the vaccinated and
unvaccinated people Healthcare seeking behavior
in general and your risk of exposure over time
so this is uh if I were John Oliver is where I
give you like a very nice neat solution to these
causal inference problems that I'd encourage
you to strongly to like always do this thing
or I'd give you like a cool hashtag tweet and
I don't have that because much to everyone's
disappointment including my own I'm not John
Oliver so the magical answer to solving these
problems for those of us who are currently
trying to estimate covid-19 ve is to spend a
lot of time thinking carefully about the models
we've specified but how they may accurately or
inaccurately describe both our population and
the questions we would like to answer and for
those of us who are attempting to interpret Cova
19 be estimates I hope this presentation is kind
of Illustrated the importance of carefully reading
the methods and the discussion sections of papers
and maybe it even helps to explain why there is
variability in ve estimates for the same vaccine
in different places or at different times or
in different groups so with that I just want
to send a thank you out to many of the wonderful
people that have done the science that's kind of
contained within this presentation um including
edlanja my boss at Marshall Clinic as well as
many wonderful colleagues uh and mentors so I'll
stop talking and I think hopefully now it'll be
time for questions hopefully you guys have some
some questions that you can challenge me with and
we can we can talk about test negative design
and covid-19 and Big Data Maria I think you're
giving John Oliver a run for his money here you
should look out for his job uh thank you so much
for what a fantastic presentation uh I've got
so many questions um you know you talked about
vaccine nationalism and equity and and uh you know
a number of different factors which influence some
of this uh kind of work I also you know couldn't
help but notice back in the when we the vaccines
were coming out that you had the moderna virus she
had the Pfizer uh the fire the Pfizer vaccine you
had you know several other contenders and those
were just within the U.S and then at other places
around the world and I'm curious that you know
we talk about the vaccine as if it's like with
a capital V but there was vaccines and I'm curious
like how some of these this modeling has to take
into account not that you just got vaccinated
but by what vaccine you were inoculated with
yeah you bring up a really excellent
point that I didn't touch on at all
um and there's there's actually a couple of
different reasons why that's super complex one
of them is um age specific or kind of high risk
specific recommendations for different vaccines
um for for example in the US now uh you can't get
the jaj unless they're 18 or over and you kind of
would not otherwise receive a vaccine um because
the US is kind of trying to prefer mRNA vaccines
um conversely in Canada um the other adenovirus
Vector vaccine the AstraZeneca vaccine was
um more easily accessible than a lot of other
vaccines and so that was rolled out first into
older adults and then as we ramped down the
the age eligibility it sort of become clear
that maybe it wasn't as safe for uh for example
women in their 30s and so then we had to like
kind of roll that back a little bit and say
okay actually um you know now now that we have
a little bit more mRNA vaccine on the market
we're going to make this recommendation that
if you're in your mid 30s and you're a woman
we would prefer that you get moderna or Pfizer
um but if that's not available and you're
a high-risk person then we want you to get
the vaccine that is available to you um and
so that like all of these kind of pieces are
changing like in real time another really
good example of that is again in Canada
um there was a longer delay between the
first and the second primary series doses
um and I'm a vaccine epidemiologist so I I'll
just kind of like this is like a very familiar
phrase to me um just to like give you an
idea of what I mean by primary doses like
the first time you got vaccinated against
government 19 is usually it's probably two
doses right so you had you had to get a shot and
then you had to come back three or four weeks
later for the second shot and that was the end
of your primary series in Canada we didn't have
enough vaccines to give everyone the primary
series on the schedule that was recommended
by the manufacturer and so my primary series I
received the first dose uh in May and the second
dose in late June um six weeks later so that's
a fairly normal kind of like uh way that a lot
of Canadians my age received mRNA vaccines
but also due to uh you know lack of vaccine
I had heterologist dosing so I received a Pfizer
vaccine for my first primary series dose and then
I received a moderna for my second primary series
dose because that was just what was available
um so like all of these there's challenges in
like identifying biomedically whether heterologous
dosing might have vaccine safety challenges for
different age groups versus maybe it has increased
immunity potential maybe the extended interval
between primary theories doses is better long-term
for your immunity but it also increases your risk
short term of getting cover 19. and so like all of
these I I think again I'm probably not being very
satisfying in like telling you like you should do
always do this always do that when you see these
things in your model but it is extraordinarily
complex and I think that's your your point
is really helpful to illustrate like the
importance of really understanding what's going on
in the community uh before you dig into the data
you know I hadn't uh heard about collider bias
before and um I imagine that it's still an
unfamiliar term to some people um how did you
first kind of encounter instances where this
is going on and uh is this something that is well
recognized within the epidemiological community um
because I'm not really sure that data scientists
you know as a species necessarily attend to things
like collider bias yeah collider bias is one of
those really odd bugaboos in like epidemiological
epidemiology methods so there's there's like a
whole like species of epidemiologists that just
focus on causal inference methods and to then I
think collider bias is like really familiar and
very understandable as you can see it can be hard
to wrap your brain around um because it's it's
this weird like accident of mathematics that kind
of winds up with like the totally wrong answer
um it's something that maybe is like on the same
you know in the same category as something called
non-collapsibility of the odds ratio which is
another problem that the methodologists worry
about a lot and then people who are kind of like
on the ground like trying to figure out if vaccine
works it's not at the top of our mind um and so
I learned about it in my PhD program but I really
didn't at the time imagine that it would ever have
any kind of like relevance to me personally and
then when we were doing this analysis in Ontario
we were saying well okay like what's the correct
comparison group for these people who are testing
positive should we include people who tested
negative so we include people who tested negative
and were symptomatic should we include people who
test them that have been we're asymptomatic those
people are probably healthcare workers and they're
probably getting like tested a lot so maybe
they're special excuse me or weird in some way and
um we wound up doing it all of the different ways
and we were really hoping that it would be the
same uh for every different comparison group
and then it would be simple but it wasn't it
really really wasn't it was quite different and
that's kind of what Illustrated to us that like
collider bias is happening here I think that's
super important certainly super important for
you know not just epidemiological research but for
all sorts of things where you may have some sort
of you know there's either a self-selection bias
or some sort of another you know effect that you
know people who are interested in whatever it
is you're interested in uh might also be those
who are the most likely to volunteer to be a
subject somehow so it affects your you think
you're sampling the population but really you're
sampling the collider whatever that happens to be
um so I think it's it's a really important thing
that we again I wasn't really familiar with and
I imagine a lot of data scientists who don't
really pay much attention to and possibly should
um you also talked about um kind of the um
unhealthy versus healthy um and you had a
nice little graphic that showed how the unhealthy
kind of drives the the ve in One Direction and
The Healthy drives it in the other direction
do those cancel each other out on the whole
or is one more powerful than another leaves a
lingering residue of bias if you know what I mean
yeah well that that's a very good question
I think it really depends on your population
so if you were to try to assess ve in a healthcare
worker population you might have healthy vaccine
bias but if you're trying to assess ve and
like care home like long-term care facility
population you might have bias towards them all
um so you know kind of a population wide level
thing like how we did in Ontario it's possible
that they cancel each other out but it's hard
to know exactly what the magnitude of either
one is in either direction unless you kind
of really have a clear understanding of
like what are the underlying structures
and how is the vaccine being prioritized
to this population or that one over time
what now people have obviously your focus is
on covid-19 vaccines and their effectiveness
these sorts of things that you've discussed
what if we replaced covid-19 vaccine with
hydrochloroquine for example and yolk would you
you would see some of these same effects you know
the biases would creep in the various uh glider
biases for whatever reason they're called they're
in are these effects are going to be present there
too am I correct yeah absolutely and for for like
Therapeutics and things like hydroxychloroquine
and you know we have like special questions that
we specifically ask about vaccines like
waning immunity or viral interference
um for Therapeutics there may be other questions
like were you taking another drug at the same time
um are are you like did you take
a drug five years ago that might
affect their pharmacology of the
drug that you're taking currently
um and so there is like a little bit of
a difference in terms of like the actual
um some of the actual bias questions because of
the biological mechanisms of the of the drug but
you're absolutely right that like General collider
bias can be found anywhere uh and especially in
places where we don't have complete or proper case
ascertainment covid-19 is a great example of that
um or where we don't um equitably assign people
to receive uh the thing that we think prevents
the outcome so vaccines or drugs as your child
is actually a pretty good example of that where
you know we feel like it works but maybe it
doesn't work as well against emicron and so
um we were continuing to provide it in certain
scenarios but there's differences in providing
practices and then it's changing over time
too with the emergence of Omicron variants
and so that also like kind of adds I guess like
a layer of complexity that not necessarily is
not necessarily like at the top of our minds
or to dining a study to to assess these things
can you comment on any other things that people
who are data scientists or who are attempting to
say take data from a national repository or some
large you know place where they could get access
to this what are some modeling techniques some
additional things that people need to be aware
of who are data scientists who are usually just
you know we're going to apply machine learning
and it's going to machines are going to sort
it all out what are some of the again there be
dragons provisions and provisos they need to be
aware of yeah well that's a very good question
um I have a couple of thoughts like things that I
would prefer to do but I'm curious if anyone else
has in the chat or online or whatever has like
thoughts of you know stuff that would be best
practices so um one of the first things that I
usually do is to do things a couple of different
ways and see if I get the same answer and if I
don't get the same answer I think I start to think
well okay maybe there's something weird happening
here and that's what happened in the Ontario data
and that's kind of how we were like oh actually
there's there's maybe some collider bias happening
um one of the ways that you could try to
find out whether the assumptions of the
test native design are held for example if
you wanted to use that design study design
is that you could analyze the data a different
way you could use like a Cox proportional hazards
model or you could use something that's not a
gln and see if you get a relatively similar ve
estimate and if you don't then that's a sign
that some of the assumptions that at least one
of your models has been violated right because in
theory there's only one underlying truth and in
theory you've built your model to estimate that
underlying truth so if it's different than the
truth if they're different from each other then
one of them is different than the trees maybe
both of them are and then you have to figure out
like difference between truth either because if
not specify my model correctly or because one
of the assumptions is broken um so so that's
kind of like why I generally tend to do that but I
think like even more than that for me um and this
is partly because I'm an academic who's like
a big procrastinator and also a curious person
I like I really like to delve into like actually
what does this data mean if we have like a
covid-19 positive in the data set does that mean
that they were tested at a community health clinic
does that mean that they reported on the phone
that they had a positive test does that mean
that they had sudden loss of taste and smell and
someone in their house had covid but they didn't
actually ever get tested does it mean that they're
a healthcare provider who had no symptoms and they
kept getting tested every single day because that
was their workplace safety requirements and then
one day it turned positive even now they they
never noticed any kind of symptoms and like all
those to me are really different and they kind of
carry with them different kind of scenarios in the
subject um so I think like it's it can be really
challenging to do this because when you're working
with something like big data it kind of comes to
you all packaged really nicely at least in a lot
of scenarios maybe not every scenario but in in
the case of the Ontario data it's like it's a nice
Cut data set we have a data dictionary we have
like a we we feel like we have like a complete
understanding of what's going on here and it's
not until like our assumptions are challenged by
the data itself that we start saying oh actually
like does this really mean my thought it meant and
I think that's where it gets into the importance
of like you you really actually it is worthwhile
to find out what that variable really means like
deep deep down um I don't know that's a little bit
of a soapbox I think from an epidemiologist but if
you don't want to do that or you can't do it maybe
you can't do it do it a lot of different ways and
see if it's different and if it's not different
then maybe maybe you really do have the right
model and that would be amazing great one final
question for you what to your mind is one of the
best data resources out there for covid-19 data
variables incidence rates you know that that would
be suitable for large-scale Mining and Analysis
a couple of different really good databases on
their website and I would actually recommend
checking them out but depending on where you
live you may also have like really good local
data that has been provided some local and like
State uh City Health departments provide that
data in Excel spreadsheets which is amazing um
otherwise I know that you can if you're like
really into it and you really want to get this
data out of their website you can do like a web
scraping they're they're cool with that some um
some states do Wastewater surveillance and they
have the Wastewater surveillance results also
posted on their website in a really nice Lake
and that's that is really big data because
that's like um they they sample wastewater
treatment facilities like with some kind of
frequency every week uh and depending on like
the size of the testing program it might be like
every Wastewater Treatment Facility in the state
over time so that's that's something that is like
very interesting I think to dig into um and you
might find something really cool or like very odd
there which I think maybe those are synonymous
um but yeah that's that's what I would do I mean
the other if you have a connection with like
um the the hospital um or the
like University Health System
um they will also have a lot of data and it's
possible that they have so much data that they
need to analyze it uh and maybe you could maybe
you could play that role so yeah I would actually
um I would take a quick look first on the CDC
website they've got a couple of really cool data
sets um for for the circulating variants and
for uh just a number of cases per day per per
um public health unit that's fantastic well Maria
thank you so much that was a very fascinating and
engaging talk I really enjoyed that I hope
that uh our kind of listeners did as well
um I want to thank you again and I want to
thank everybody who uh joined us both here
in Zoom as well as out on YouTube um do I do
encourage you to apply for our biomedical data
science Innovation lab uh event coming up and uh
with a deadline for applications is January 8th
so please consider doing that if you're a junior
faculty interested in um covid-19 the second very
health effects and the role that data science
can play we'd love to entertain your materials
in the meantime everyone have a wonderful
weekend and we'll see you next week thank